the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the how do you do y'all
we're over here doing it in the night
pants Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler and all
your social media and again thank you
guys thank you for supporting this
channel thank you for supporting this
show thank you for supporting the guests
on this show you guys are the best fans
um it's like when your kids go over for
a sleepover and then when they come back
the parents are like your children are
so well mannered and so nice you're like
yeah that's what I hear about the the I
I usually say don't read YouTube
comments but the comments you guys make
for these episodes and the guests are
just something that changes their lives
so thank you very much for doing that
um as I've said YouTube killed my
special they pulled it out of the
algorithm and all that so you got to go
find it so go look for it tell everybody
support it it's been a lot of work and a
lot of money uh doing that for YouTube
just to say nah
um if you gotta have more then you gotta
check out the patreon I'm telling you
every week about the patreon because
it's the wildest stories it's the
Honeydew with y'all and y'all have way
crazier stories you just didn't decide
to be comedians about it so we're
talking to uh people who've solved cold
cases who've died and come back a dude
who had a double lung trans uh plant and
and then married the donor's
ex-girlfriend and they just had a kid
Congratulations by the way we got the
email happy for you dude you stole your
you stole that dude's long and his girl
now you have his family you son of a oh
congrats it's five bucks and if you or
someone you know has a wild story that
has to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com if you're
looking for a new podcast to listen to
go listen to my old podcast I'm telling
you it's the crab Feast it's the
storytelling podcast and it's got
everybody you know in comedy on it Bill
Burr Chrysler segora Christina P
everybody's been on it it's a seven and
a half year Library go check it out
um and come see me on tour all right
I've got a bunch of dates we're adding
for the rest of this year and then a
gang of next year we're going my lungs
are feeling better uh so uh this weekend
actually yeah June 23rd and 24th I'll be
up in Tacoma Washington where are you at
Tacoma June 23rd and 24th I'm there
Friday and Saturday and then July 7th
and 8th Appleton Wisconsin go to uh Ryan
sickler.com for tickets all right
now you know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights I always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers I'm very excited to have
this guest on today first time here on
the Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Rachel Wolfson welcome to the
Honeydew rate thank you so much for
having me thank you thank you for being
here we've talked about it for a little
bit we have
um and then I think you Caitlin by the
way thank you my girl Caitlin hit me up
with your number because I never got
your info that night and I'm off my
social media and I think you messaged me
I think that's great that you're off on
social media is that like helped with
your mind yes okay maybe I need to check
on it so I know things are going on I'm
there I'm present with it I certainly
respond you know if it's something nice
but I've done that no I can't I was I
was
sitting next to my daughter one day and
she's like Dad can we play can we play
I'm like I'm gonna do this stupid post
and I'm like what what the hell am I
doing 30 minutes of my day doing posts
for what it's a job now I I don't like I
personally this is just me talking about
me I've taken my social media as far as
I can it now like when I laid in the
hospital and I had nothing to do but try
to live I just looked at social media
apps and I watched different Trends on
this one and music on this one I was
like man this is this is a job for
someone and it's you know you really
need someone knows how to do it and I
don't know how to do it I think that's
like true success is like not being on
social media yeah I agree there's it's
gonna switch at some point like all
these people are on it and then at some
point like every culture gets anti like
we're not gonna do that so social media
be this thing they don't do and they'll
figure out another thing and then it'll
come back again we'll have to talk to
each other in person yeah remember
listen I really think that like I know
there's this thing today at least with a
lot of like younger girls and older guys
and I just think it's because older guys
know how to talk to women because we
didn't have a social media like we had
to suck it up and walk across the bar in
front of our friends knowing nine times
out of ten just to get rejected yes
and it builds up a a little bit of a
metal and it builds up a self-esteem in
a way too we're like I'm getting used to
this now like I'm not scared to go over
and do it I think that's what it is I
don't think it's this like oh these
daddies or whatever I just think these
guys are like oh I just know how to
treat you like a person you're not just
someone I go wanna bang no swipe wanna
bang no swipe wanna bang me I have to
talk to you and invest time in you and
and learn how to tell you who I am and
be comfortable with that it doesn't
really exist now you can get rejected by
a hundred women on social media in 10
minutes in 10 minutes but you think your
statistics though there's got to be like
at least one or two who like would
consider yeah you know so it kind of
yeah that's it I remember a babysitter
of mine she's a beautiful Italian girl
and she said I finally went online and
I go show me how many dudes no and she
went like I thought her skin was gonna
fall off her finger she was scrolling so
much she goes my guy friend did it he's
got three oh yeah and I said so wait so
Mr Wright could mathematically be in
this mix she's like aha I go but you
would have to date she's like I guess
I started a whole DM's account actually
on Instagram based off all the DMS I've
received
um pretty much since the movies come out
it's a collection of humbling moments
really
um I have a whole series called Almost
compliments and I think the best one I
got was someone wrote that I'm way too
hot to have no ass
yeah so um really well took me down a
few notches but I appreciate it so it
was literally a backhanded compliment so
I remember
um one of the best I've seen on the spot
was Matt Fulshear on we were at the
Irvine Improv the old Irvine Improv
years ago and we got done we were in the
lobby just you know handing out CDs or
whatever back in the day what are those
right and this girl came up to Matt and
she went you're kind of funny and on the
spot he went you're kind of pregnant and
I mean boom Oh my God out the door now I
was like
I've never forgotten all right before we
get into what we're gonna talk about
thank you again for being here please
plug promote everything Rachel wolf
um so you can follow me on Instagram
Rachel Wolfson Twitter at wolfy comedy
venmo at wolfy comedy then you can
follow me on my website Rachel
wolfsoncomedy.com that has my shows and
I have shows coming up in Tampa and
Miami Miami's July 21st Tampa is the
23rd and also Palm Springs or Indio in
November but I'll have spots in between
as well shows and whatnot so just check
my website
and you mentioned you're in Jackass the
latest yeah yes that came out
um about a year ago I think yeah yeah
over a year ago I watched you on my
flight because it's the it's on the
airplane well it's the uh I had
downloaded on Netflix but it's not the
full movie what is it two point what is
it 4.5 it's basically yeah four point
the point fives are like
documentary style and Things That
Couldn't um that didn't fit in the movie
but were so good that they had to it's
basically extra footage yeah
so what'd you think I thought it was
great okay I mean I love all those guys
from back in the day even the CKY and
all that stuff
um so I also want to say this because
this is a very interesting thing about
you we just call tried to call Segura
outside to tell him because you just
said you did ymh I was like God damn it
because I was gonna tell Tom today that
I was having you on okay and who your
mom is yeah and what your mom did
because Tom and I have this affection
for OJ's uh Simpsons absurdity with the
just like why are they asking me about
the Murdoch murders well maybe because
you have history with multiple murders
maybe that's a reason opinions I love
them yeah yeah I'm a follower of his
Twitter as well so tell us before we get
into your whole life story tell
everybody about your mom and what
happened so um because listen also I'm
interrupting but that's what um
introduced me to you is your clip I
think it's at the Laugh Factory where
you said that I was like who's this girl
yeah so my connection to OJ is my mom
was the presiding judge over his robbery
case that took place in Las Vegas and
um it was
um she was the one yeah who presided
over his case and the jury
sent him to prison for it I think he got
9 to 33 years and like served I think I
don't know nine or something
um did he really do that long nine he
actually did that I think so but I don't
yeah he didn't do the full like the
um dudes back there stealing his old
cleats and [__] he's yeah he's out
living in Vegas
um the same town where my family lives
and um so yeah that's basically my
connection to it and I just I have a
joke about it and
um yeah what is it your mom put OJ in
prison so my mom uh the uh my mom was
the judge who put O.J Simpson in prison
so basically O.J Simpson
um got sent to prison by the same woman
who sent me to my room but
but we got out
so yeah here you are
yeah
um well tell me about your life growing
up then
um so I was born and raised in Las Vegas
and
um my parents at the time were both
lawyers and they had a law firm together
criminal defense
um they met at the courthouse my mom was
a TV news reporter and my dad was a
prosecutor in the prosecutor's office
and he used to watch my mom on TV and he
said that he was going to marry that
woman
and so they would just cross paths at
work my mom would be reporting on
stories my dad would be you know
um going obsessing over
and um and your mom had no idea this
dude liked her like that at first uh
probably not because you know it was
before
social media and there's uh it you know
you actually had to hit on a woman
um most likely at work
but they uh so they started dating they
got married my mom
um before they got married she went to
law school and then they eventually
opened up a law firm together and my mom
um she was always
um working in this male dominated field
such as like TV news reporting and then
moving on to be a criminal defense
attorney
um so yeah they opened up a law firm
together they had me
um then they had my sister she's four
and a half years younger than me
um
and yeah they raised us in Las Vegas and
um yeah that's
yeah what else do you want your
background that's pretty much yeah um
they I was uh I um first good kid were
you a good student no I was uh I I was
diagnosed with ADHD at five and why what
made your parents look into that
um I couldn't sit still I was a
distraction
um I I you know I couldn't pay attention
um I wouldn't listen I was
um
defiant
and I think a lot of it was I like
school I had a hard time concentrating
so they had me evaluated and um I was
really originally diagnosed with
Oppositional Defiant Disorder at five
I've never even heard of that what is
that odd I think it's traditional
defiant yeah disorder I think it like
morphed into ADHD or something but it's
like what is that just saying like I
don't want to do this I think honestly I
was just one of those kids that got like
obviously I I have issues but I was one
of those kids that got medicated really
early on stimulants so
um I was diagnosed with that at five and
then when I was 12 I was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder and put on lithium okay
hold on let's pause there for a second
then does that mean excuse me that the
initial diagnosis of ADHD was incorrect
and all along it was
um I don't think so I think a lot of
these diagnosis is run
um like
together yeah so
um
so I was diagnosed bipolar which ended
up being borderline personality disorder
which I got diagnosed in college
and I found out that so ADHD at 5 at 12
is borderline is bipolar I'm sorry
bipolar and that was a misdiagnosis okay
and you believe the ADHD was no I think
I definitely have ADHD okay so that was
accurate all right so
um I found out when I was older actually
recently that
um a lot of people I think get diagnosed
bipolar instead of borderline because
um they like the I think the doctors or
the insurance companies or something
can't bill for it it's like really
[__] up oh because there's no
medication you can take for borderline
it's just talk therapy like you can get
medicated for like let's say you have
depression or anxiety which can run
along
um borderline as well but for borderline
specifically there's no medication for
it so oftentimes they'll diagnose you as
bipolar
a lot of like
um discourse on Twitter about other
people who've had that same experience
and ultimately then you're getting
medicated for things that you might not
have right so I was on lithium at 12 and
I developed a thyroid disorder because
of it and I gained a lot of weight and
my mom took me to Weight Watchers
not thinking about the lithium thinking
about well I was at that well at that
point
um I had to get tested for thyroid
disorder and it was linked to the
lithium because you have to get tested
blood tests every few months if you're
on lithium what does lithium do to you
um I think it's like I think it's like a
heavy like mood stabilizer
antidepressant basically I just remember
yeah looking like zonked out yeah
there's a lot of like memory gaps in my
life where people will tell me something
happened and I just have zero memory of
it because I was on a lot of medication
like
um I was on Seroquel at one point which
is a tranquilizer
and yeah so
there's gaps in my memory
and so 12 you're on this and you develop
a thyroid issue came off the lithium my
thyroid like got readjusted I lost the
weight
um and yeah
and then um I went to when I was dying I
was diagnosed at UCLA Medical Center
um the hospital here when I was 12.
that's how they diagnosed me
okay so how long were you on that
lithium
um not very long okay yeah it was
probably like less than a year
um because I had to come off because of
the thyroid and then you start entering
High School
and are you just on ADHD meds no I'm on
um I'm on ADHD meds and I'm also on
antidepressants mood stabilizers
anti-anxiety that's a lot for a kid and
what's it doing to you is it helping or
is it what do you say it was doing to
you do you feel like it helped you or do
you feel like it hindered you in ways I
think I got I know it numb me out
um I think that I because of the
medication that I was on I I wasn't able
to really process a lot of the issues
that were underlying what I was going
through and that's what has come out in
my 20s and my 30s tell me what were you
doing
um it's a lot of um well with borderline
the basis of it is
um it's a person has unstable moods
behaviors and relationships and you
think who doesn't have that right but
it's really
um not having the emotional regulation
and tools to handle the
um those feelings that you know other
people might be able to handle like for
me when I experience rejection and
abandonment it's end of the world it's
emotions that like I I just experience
it at such a high level that I have to
use tools whether it be like going to
the freezer and getting an ice pack to
physically calm those the the intensity
that I'm feeling so everyone has those
emotions right anger sadness whatever
minor dialed up to 10.
so it's like
it's just basically
um emotional dysregulation and that
leads to a lot of instability in a lot
of areas in your life
so
yeah and the only way to deal with that
is talk therapy a specific talk therapy
called DBT what is it DBT it stands for
dialectical behavior therapy and it's
talk therapy so that when you get
triggered because a lot of these
emotions are from a trigger and then
um there are these tools that you're
supposed to implement to handle the
emotional dysregulation that you
experience when you get triggered like
something will happen I'll get triggered
and I'm so emotionally disregulated that
I lose my identity
um I I like my thoughts are so dark I'm
not able like it's good that I have my
boyfriend who is so educated on
borderline it's almost I I'm almost
scared to sometimes be alone with my
thoughts because I need someone there to
tell me that that's just my emotions
it's not facts because I get lost in
that so so you have to you know you have
to learn how to self-regulate
self-validate do all these things and a
lot of this is because I didn't learn it
as a kid
and so do you disassociate yes you do
for how long
it could be days sometimes really and
it's just curl up in a ball and not
communicating I just like I I'm just in
this drag yourself out and do sets it's
the worst sometimes I do and I'm crying
right before I get on stage I'm so in
this dark place that I like sometimes
stand up pulls me out I gotta be honest
because sometimes I'm in the worst place
I'll be crying even like I'll be drying
my tears as I walk on stage
no you don't even know like I I that
happened at moon tower I was so sad and
I walked on stage and luckily it was so
hot I was also sweating so like you know
one could tell where the moisture was
coming from and um and then as soon as
that first laugh happens there's a
release inside me it's the validation
that I need that like I'm not giving
myself or that I can't in that moment
because I'm so emotionally disregulated
give me an example of a time that this
happened to you where it was really one
of your worst
um
I get triggered a lot
with well for example in LA
you know there's a lacking of stage time
and I think for me
um I just I got the movie and I was
three years into comedy when the movie
came out and so my whole thing was I
wanted to be a stand-up I want to master
this craft I want to become a beast I
know it takes you know 10 000 hours to
be good at something and then you know
when the movie came out I I don't think
I I think I I just didn't get as many
spots as I thought I would I thought
some of the clubs might open up to me I
still don't have a home Club here and
for me I just
um
I get really triggered sometimes that
um I I'm not there yet
in La specifically in the town that I
started in and that
um
yeah I I basically I came up in so
sometimes you know
um when I I don't get booked or I get
the emails and for months I won't get
booked I'll
it'll just I'll get really upset about
it and luckily with Matt he's a paid
regular at the store he's been in the
scene I have someone like that to tell
me like that this is normal this is
something that everyone goes through you
know and took me 20 I know two years
yeah and and everybody's different yeah
and Matt like he he has these stories
because he's been in it for 16 years and
he tells me like without that I would I
wouldn't know that this is normal I
wouldn't have someone who's mentoring me
because in comedy you need those mentors
you need people to sit you down and be
like you know and and
um not critique you but give good
feedback and guide you in the direction
you know like Felipe Esparza is a mentor
of mine he started taking me on the road
really early and he's just been the best
Mentor I've ever had him in his way wife
Lisa like anytime I have any question
about comedy or the business you know
they're there to to lend an ear or offer
guidance so
for me on top of like the level of like
like how I handle rejection and
abandonment because I'm a hustler when I
when I like got into comedy I hit the
ground running five mics a night in La
like riding every day getting up as much
as I can and then once the pandemic hit
a lot of those mics disappeared and I've
kind of watched the scene in La really
dry up for like newer comics and I
before the pandemic like I said I was
three years in and now I'm seven and I
feel like I'm part of this like
forgotten class where like we're still
not Headliners per se well I'm
headlining now but like you know we
don't get enough of the Reps that we
should hear specifically so we have to
go on the road we have to go elsewhere
you know so it's it's also okay to do
that yeah listen a building with your
name on it although it's legendary and
fun and great and everything it doesn't
make you who you are or who you aren't
either by the way yeah it doesn't you go
out on the road you build your hour you
build your fan base you go out there and
hopefully you get to do some spots in La
there's yeah
I mean three legit clubs
and I'm not including the Laugh Factory
shade in L.A no I know it's only so many
stages and there's a million of us you
know 100 and I I think it takes leaving
the scene to realize how much stage time
there is out there and so you know I've
been I've been stuck in La for a while
because up until the strike happened
I've been shooting
um TV and stuff so I haven't been able
to get out on the road as much because
obviously like I'm not going to just sit
around and wait for stage time but when
you're shooting stuff it's difficult
it's more difficult to go on the road I
don't you know I don't
um yeah I just I had to be in town for
these last six months plus and now that
that's over and the strikes happening
I'm like okay let's get out on the road
and I just got back from Austin and it's
so cool to see that scene kind of start
I love it and there's like 10 comedy
clubs there and you can walk to like all
of them
and that's right if I was a comedian
especially if I wanted to build the
muscle of stand-up comedy and I wasn't
already where I am and I didn't have a
child that lives here so I stay here
um I definitely would go down there you
can get up and do five five six a night
yeah I already saw the comic that I was
like you know like for me I need reps
like I feel like I've kind of plateaued
out here specifically because you know
there's only so much stage time to go
around so again I need to be out there
but also not to interrupt you but when
you come here you're out there you're
working on an hour when you come here
you got to work yeah seven to Fifteen
pieces of your hour so even though you
need the Reps you're getting reps on
only the chunks you choose to do that
night you're not getting the Reps on
that full 45 or hour you know right so
there's that too you know right there's
a lot of people who can Crush 15 and
don't have anything beyond that and so
that's why for me I I wanna you know I
wanna have an hour of really solid jokes
and so
um I'm at a point where now that I have
the
um time and I'm able to go out on the
road I'm I'm much happier with where I
am because for a while I felt really
stuck being in LA and not being able to
like
um work on my stand up the way I want to
so let's go back a little bit in time
for you and tell me about you mentioned
to me outside about your senior year in
high school you went to a different
school and why what was it and why did
that happen
um so
you know I was having behavioral issues
since I was a kid and I think it all
came to a haul my senior year I got
caught sinking out of the house and do
what make out with boys and
um
my parents caught me and at that point
that was kind of like a cry for help I
was
um not doing well mentally and were you
using any drugs or anything at the time
no I'm drinking no no for me it was all
mental and I just think that
you know my parents they were they just
worked really really hard and they
weren't able to you know
um
they didn't give me the emotional tools
I think because they just one I don't
know if they even have them like I
watched the way my grandfather kind of
treated my mom and my grandma and my
aunts and I think that gets passed down
generationally and so my mom to be able
to do the jobs that she had which is be
a judge be a criminal defense attorney
you know you almost have to be stoic and
that got brought home so you know as a
kid like for me I just never felt good
enough like if I didn't get an A you
know I wouldn't get validated for
whatever grade I did get and so I didn't
learn to validate myself like even when
I played basketball it was like
I wasn't good enough at whatever I did
out there and I know that my parents
that's also a generational thing like
we're kids need to be validated from a
young age we don't need to be babied we
need to be validated like I didn't need
to be babied but I did need to feel good
about whatever it was that I'm doing and
I think for high achieving parents it's
hard to kind of like
you know it's kind of hard to give that
to a kid because no kids high most of
them are not high achieving you know and
or but they they grow into whatever it
is and so
you know I struggled with a lot of that
I was very you know just
I just never felt really good or worthy
or
um I didn't have any self-esteem so
I think that I sought that out in
boys and so when I got caught my parents
were concerned and my mom found a school
in Utah that was a therapeutic boarding
school it's basically a lockdown there's
bars on the Windows surreal yeah
and they take your shoes when you get
there and once you go
you can't leave until you graduate the
program
and they manipulate your parents
um so that they won't tell me about it
get you
so they'll lie to your parents to tell
them you're fine so they're like this is
normal she's going to want to come home
she's going to say this she's gonna say
that and that's normal hair changes can
happen due to age biology and lifestyle
so no matter the root cause of your hair
concerns neutrophone meets you exactly
where you are with science back formulas
tailored to your needs while neutrifolds
hair growth supplements Target the root
causes of thinning hair from within
neutrophils scalp Care Formulas help
create a healthy environment for
improved hair quality when your scalp is
unbalanced or not cared for regularly
with the right products it can become
clogged dry and irritated leading to a
poor environment for natural hair growth
the shampoo scalp mask and scalp Essence
are each gentle yet effective and work
to exfoliate purify and balance the
scalp for improved hair Health the
sulfate and silicone free shampoo and
conditioner are designed to cleanse the
scalp without stripping and defend the
strands for stronger more voluminous
hair take the first step towards
improved hair and scalp Health now for a
limited time neutral Falls offering our
U.S listeners ten dollars off your first
scalp care order when you go to
neutrifold.com
scalp and enter promo code honeydew find
out why over 4 000 Healthcare
professionals recommend neutrifol for
healthier Hair
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com slash scalp and
enter promo code honeydew for ten
dollars off your first scalp care order
this is available only to us customers
for a limited time that's neutrifold.com
scalp promo code honeydew for ten
dollars off your first scalp care order
there's no quick fix for anxiety and
depression it's not finding a new
therapist or starting an exercise
routine not more in regular meditation
or a better diet sometimes you need
something to unlock your brain a new way
of thinking about and seeing the world
maybe that thing is guided ketamine
therapy from mind Bloom there is a new
tool to improve your mental health at
home ketamine therapy mind Bloom is the
leader in at home ketamine therapy
having safely helped thousands of people
overcome their anxiety and depression
unlike traditional talk therapy ketamine
Works quickly and doesn't have the
unpleasant side effects of traditional
antidepressants in a study of over 1200
mind Bloom clients 89 reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions right
now mind Bloom is offering my listeners
a hundred dollars off your first
succession program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Honeydew and use promo
code honeydew take the first step and
break free from your anxiety and
depression with mind Bloom mindbloom.com
honeydew and use promo code honeydew
proper functional hydration is essential
and liquid IV is the number one powdered
hydration brand in America they're
hydration multiplier is the one product
you're missing in your daily routine in
just one stick you're getting five
essential vitamins two times faster
hydration than water alone use it first
thing in the morning before a workout
when you feel run down after law long
night out long flights whatever all
right I take it on the tour we're taking
it here at the studio I give it out to
friends I love it it it's a great pick
me up in the morning I take it in my
water to physical therapy with me it's
money 12 delicious refreshing flavors to
keep your hydration routine exciting
contains five essential vitamins B3 B5
B6 B12 and vitamin C has three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks and it's made with premium
ingredients that are non-GMO and free
from gluten dairy and soy real people
real flavor real hydrating grab your
liquid IV and bulk nationwide at Costco
or you can get 20 off when you go to
liquid iv.com and use code honey do a
checkout that's 20 off of anything when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code honeydew and liquid iv.com
now let's get back to the do so
um
you know and then when you get there so
if my parents found a school is in Provo
Utah and they took me and and dropped me
off
um which is something that I think about
that it's crazy that they just like took
me and dropped me off they didn't drive
you mm-hmm and a lot of well I was one
of the lucky ones because a lot of the
kids that I went with there they get
what we call escorted which is when two
huge security guards come into your room
at night and basically kidnap you
and bring you to the school what and
then there's your home out of your home
in the middle of the night which is so
incredibly traumatized yeah that's how
they're coming to get you you're
sleeping and they grab you and throw you
I was one of the lucky ones like the
whole experience is traumatizing but to
go through that just to get to that
that's something that I think a lot of
people who go through that experience is
basically illegal kidnapping it's it's
traumatizing and then there's the other
[__] up way that you get there is when
your parents tell you you're going on a
ski trip and they make you pack your
bags and they drop you off at that
facility is that what happened to you no
but I knew exactly where I was going I
just didn't know what would happen when
I got there I'm thinking it's like Harry
Potter I'm gonna learn magic you know
I'm Gonna Learn spells like you know I'm
gonna make out with boys in Utah in
these like with these horny Mormons who
don't get enough attention no it was
nothing like that what was it like uh a
lockdown it was like basically kid
prison I mean you when are you in a room
the door locks as well or you're always
watched you're never alone you're
separated from the boys you don't have
shoes the first I don't know a couple
weeks you get there you have to earn
um your only communication is for the
first two months letters two people your
parents pre-approved you could write to
and everything you write gets written
read and everything Becca sent to you
gets read so they know everything that's
being said in and out of that then you
have roommates
um you lit there's different rooms at
the
um school and depending like I lived in
a room that had two
12 girls in it bunk beds damn and but
they're you know some rooms had eight
some rooms had a couple there's
different rooms that you live in and
give me the range of what people are
there for you're there for sneaking out
and trouble with boys and what are some
other drugs addiction
um some kids are court ordered there so
violent Behavior she's just thrown in
with a hodgepodge of whatever troubled
mental mental issues yeah it's called
Trump troubled youth schools
basically troubled teens yeah
okay so and they range so you can go
there as young as I I think the youngest
they had there was 13 and then 18. so I
went when I was 17 and I turned 18 in
Utah and when you turn 18
so there's a law when you turn 18 in
Utah you can't live you can't you can't
you can't be housed with underage kids
or something so they have to put you in
the 18 year old house and you also have
to sign your rights away saying that
you're not going to leave the school
until you graduate the program that's
what I want to ask because now you're an
adult
so basically what they tell you is if
you don't so your birthday is coming up
they know that you have the option to
leave legally or and and if you do leave
they tell you're going to be homeless
and that they're going to call your
parents and tell them not to pick you up
the entire town is going to know not to
basically help you
and yeah they basically say you'll be
homeless but then and but so you so
basically if you do sign you have to
stay until you graduate the program so
when did you turn 18 and how many more
months before so I got there in November
of 2000
um
I got there in November and I turned 18
January so I was only
um I was only in the underage for
November and December up until January
23rd and then June you graduate like
regular school or no I graduated that
December I I graduated a whole semester
after my class so you spent another year
there after I was there for 13 months
total man tell me tell me what the ride
was like with your parents were you
fighting it were you
um what was it like when they dropped
you off I was just I think for me
because so my parents uh they sent me to
private school in Vegas but it was
Private religious school
and it wasn't like they weren't like
college prep these were
schools that were often very
indoctrinating and so I went to pre-k
through 8th grade was a Jewish school
and then they didn't have a Jewish high
school so my mom sent me to Catholic
School my freshman year and
um
uh I just I didn't like it there and my
mom sent me there because it was close
to work so it was convenient for her but
I didn't really have any friends because
a lot of those kids grew up in the
Catholic school system and I grew up you
know going to a Jewish school so it was
like I was the new chick you know and it
was hard to make friends and so
um but I had a ton of friends at this
Lutheran School
that was closer to home so I went there
and that was the school that I left
before I got to send to Utah so I went
from Lutheran to Mormon
oh it was a Mormon school then it wasn't
a Mormon in school it was just ran by
all Mormons and there were certain
elements that I'm like oh they're
indoctrinating us
for sure we dress like we they made us
wear these like super long potato sack
khaki skirts and like baggy t-shirts it
was like you know just
and you know we weren't allowed there
you know you don't have sex until you're
married and
you know just
very Mormon stuff what was your first
night there like were you scared were
you angry were you I saw you visually
count the girls in the room so I know
you know what it looks like yeah the
first night well the first
the first I don't know however many
months it was like it was like the first
three months I cried myself to sleep
pretty much every night the first night
was rough I was so scared I remember
like just crying myself to sleep like I
was in a shock because I I mean I went
to summer camp but this was a whole new
world that I had just stepped into and I
don't think I knew what it I I had no
idea what to expect and then as soon as
reality hit and I was like oh I this is
my reality for
who knows how long and
um
it really made me appreciate you know
what I had even though it wasn't perfect
I think
although this place I personally think
is really messed up I think I needed to
go through something like that in some
way you do
I don't know I think things like that
build character and you know you're
going to be traumatized by life in so
many different ways and it's like if
this is one of the worst things that
I've gone through then good riddance
like
you know but it it made me who I am and
I can't take it back so yeah
so what point do you shift in there to
where you're like I can handle this so
you really figured out you gotta fake it
to make it kind of thing like you really
um you fight it first because you're
just like this is so messed up and
um you know you really are you're trying
to fight it you're trying to fight
whatever and you also don't realize like
it's kind of not a game but
you know who do you trust there's Le
there's a level system to this so it's
like you know there's girls who are more
advanced than you and there's this kind
of thing where if you're doing something
wrong they'll nark on you to make
themselves look better so it's like you
also have to learn what all the rules
are there's so many rules and if you
don't follow them you'll get in trouble
like what
um
if you you can get in trouble for
manipulation meaning like if you don't
accept no for an answer and you ask
again that will be a consequence and
you'll have to like do homework or work
out or clean the tampon boxes or
something is that what they make you do
that kind of [__]
a lot of cleaning
and so
um yeah you have to you have to do
everything they basically say
and you know if you don't there's people
there who are going to tell on you
and do you not see your parents that
entire time you're there are they
allowed you have to earn visitation that
comes after you
um get more advanced in your program and
you earn certain Privileges and one of
those is your parents coming to see you
and how often did they get to come see
you um
since I was there for a year probably a
couple times yeah and what was that like
um it was hard because it was one of
those things where
my parents you could see they were
definitely manipulated and there was
like nothing I could really say or do
because if you try to talk about it like
that they can go to your therapist and
say like she's not working on her
program she wants to get out she doesn't
you know so
um
I was my dad could just see that I was
really
bummed I was just not myself obviously
and I'm in this situation where I feel
so alone like I feel in a way that my
family's kind of abandoned me and turned
on me and left me in this place that I'm
not really sure is equipped to even be
you know dealing with kids and their
problems
and so I could see my dad I remember we
were at they took us out to eat you know
because the food kind of sucked where we
were
um so we you know when my parents came
to town they got to take you out and
have real food and stuff oh they're
allowed to take you out of the building
and have real food what if they just
right there wanted to say screw it and
take you they could they could yeah
um and some parents did come get their
kids because they figured out this was
not okay there was something going on
um because some kids got hurt there in
what ways one kid got a broom shoved up
his ass what yeah
and the mom came and got him
mm-hmm
so some aggressive people in there as
well that sounds like a mini prison it I
I hate to compare it to prison because
it sounds like it but it is it's not a
school right it's a lockdown like you
can't leave there's bars on the Windows
like it looks like a prison like I was
in the middle of nowhere like if you try
to get out of there you're just in the
middle of now as a kid when you see bars
on the windows that does something to
you you know it's like you are bad
you're not allowed especially when
you're seeing it you need to be kept
away from society you are bad you are
not like them you know it does something
so
yeah
um my parents took me to out and I just
I was looking down just like this my dad
was like this is good this is good for
you this is good for you you're gonna
get through this you know and so but
there was nothing I could say you know I
just had to because no matter what you
said they've already been told
I'm gonna complete the program I have to
complete the I have to complete the
program to get out like there's nothing
I can do I just have to take it
and did you suffer any fights or abuse
or anything in there
I didn't I didn't get into any fights
um
they did take me off my medication at
one point because a doctor didn't think
I was bipolar
and when they took me off the medication
I had a freak out and they put me in
this thing called ISU
which is isolated supervision units
where they take your bra they take
um they take anything that you could
hang yourself with and they basically
make you
sit on the floor for however many days
or days they determine that you have to
be in there and it's a closet it's
literally a closet and what was your
freak out that made them put you in this
what triggered it is
um I was in school which
the school structure is such a joke but
there's math day and English day and I
[__] hate math I still I'm like I I
just I don't understand the language and
I would put off math last so I wanted to
work on English and my teacher the math
teacher didn't want me to do that and so
I he started to take away my book and
that I freaked the [__] out and I just I
I don't remember like at this point I
was on Seroquel so or you know I'm
coming off whatever that is but I
remember just being out of control like
just out of [__] control and so they
they put me in that isolation unit
and how long were you in there I think
just a day
and then what you go back to your
regular room then you you know I think
you get you get in trouble you get some
consequences you have to talk to your
therapist you know you have to like
you know you that'll hurt your program
that'll hurt you advancing until you
have to stay there longer essentially
so when you finally get out what's it
like when your parents come to get you
are you relieved are you pissed are you
just what what are your feelings
um so I graduated and technically that's
where my high school diploma is from
this school and so what's it say on your
diploma
um again
the mascot
this guy is a picture of Ritalin it's
literally just a pill and
yeah
or the Provo prozacs
so yeah we uh panic attacks no more like
we you know that so they they come to
get me I have a graduation ceremony if
you will call it that yeah what was it
what do they do are you cap and gal yeah
are you really down but it's like
everyone who graduated in that like time
frame so it's like a bunch of other kids
and your parents come and some of the
other students will like read things
about you and and then that's it and so
I was only at home for a month before I
went off to college in Vermont which is
basically the opposite of Utah yeah I
mean you went way the other way Vegas
and Utah I went to Vermont all right so
what my so basically when I got out it
was I mean I had nightmares for years
sometimes I still have nightmares wow
what what are you seeing um basically
I'm being dragged by my feet and I'm I'm
clawing the ground and they're pulling
me into the school
into the school not that room into the
whole school into the where I entered
when my parents first and by the way the
school is an abandoned church it's
really hunting when you look at it and
they they closed down the school but
opened it up under a different name so
it's still there it is
so I I have nightmares like that I have
nightmares just being there and just
like not being able to get out
yeah
and so
I was relieved when I first got out I
was still
I was still like I was one of those like
just grateful initially I was really
grateful for just like a private shower
being able to shave my legs because if
you want to shave they have to watch you
oh really so you don't kill yourself or
cut yourself
um having privacy
that was a big thing having just being
able to Independence autonomy being able
to go somewhere by myself without having
to ask for permission being able to go
to the bathroom whenever I wanted after
every meal you have to wait an hour so
that the people who have learning or um
eating disorders
don't throw up or
participate in eating disorder but you
don't have to wait to all have to
so just something like that being able
to go to the bathroom when I wanted was
like oh this is amazing
soda made you it did make you appreciate
what you had then yeah it did and the
thing is about that place is again like
for me it's like I don't
I don't I wouldn't take it back I mean I
wouldn't wish it upon anyone but I
wouldn't take it back but there are
people there who it's all about
perspective right like there are people
there who came from such a [__] up
home life that that place was somehow
better
so it's like really all about
perspective even though what was
happening there and what that place is
may not be right or correct it was still
better from what they came from
and that was eye-opening to me is like
seeing like oh wow they're like
we're kind of this like forgotten
children this generation of like kids
who were just fed pills and they thought
oh that'll fix everything right because
our parents generation they just didn't
talk about feelings you know and they
didn't really have the medication it was
like you'll just get beat you know yeah
yeah and like that's how you learn how
to be a person and I think that's why a
lot of like my parents generation just
emotionally are really [__] up because
they weren't allowed to express
themselves because if guys did that
you're gay and if women did that you're
crazy yeah so
um and that's why we are so [__] up as
Millennials we don't know how to for the
most part process our emotions we we
didn't learn to validate ourselves
because our parents didn't get validated
so
um and and I read something where
there's there's something like
considered like there's obviously
generational wealth but there's also
something called like mental wealth and
that's where your parents really and
it's not obviously just the parents
fault but
you know because there's environment
versus
um uh what is it biology or whatever
like your environment versus like what
actually happens
um
like is it your environment or was it
mentally always were you mentally always
going to have that kind of thing so like
what caused it was it like yeah so
anyways
um
I just think that it's not just the
parents fault but I think that
if if people had better tools to handle
their emotions that's a lot of the
reason why
um we have the issues that we have with
mental health I think
we just don't know how to like
handle our emotions and process them and
emotionally regulate have you talked to
your parents about that school since
yeah we've had conversations
um you know I for me it's like I don't
blame them
because I truly know like I for me I'm
on the side of parents for the most part
are just doing the best they can I'm not
a I'm not a parent and that's why I
can't I don't place blame on them
because I truly believe they are trying
to do the best like I can only imagine
what it's like to be a parent and their
kids having an issue whether it be
medically mentally that's one there's so
much self-blame that probably goes on
and also just you know it's expensive to
try and figure out what's wrong with
your kid there's so much emotion that
goes into being a parent and the world
really doesn't support it either so
I just think that
um for me there's just a mutual
understanding of they understand that
maybe that wasn't the right place for me
and I understand that they were trying
to just do the best they could so do you
think it helped you
um
you know I don't I don't know because
if you look at a lot of the kids that
went there
most of them are like not doing great
there's only a couple that I would say a
lot of them have died a lot of them are
in yeah whether it be suicide or
overdose a lot of them had gotten
pregnant right after they graduated
um some of them have like multiple
children with multiple different you
know unstable relationships and then
there's like a few that have really
pulled themselves out of like basically
being re-traumatized or going through
that experience and not really been
given any tools to actually
succeed in the adult world because they
don't really give you those there and so
other than that like you know a lot of
people are in and out of jail
never really did anything with
themselves some got pregnant too early
or
and some are um passed away a lot of
them there's only a handful of them that
have have
done something with themselves
do you want to be a parent
um
I think for me uh I'm 36 years old and I
just feel like if I'm supposed to do
that it'll happen but I also am at a
place where
I just I don't know if I would want to
raise a child in this world
if that makes sense it makes sense
but you know I mean if I go if I think
if you if I got blessed with that that
would be great I just
it's not like my focus I guess but
you're not it's not because you're
worried that you might have a child who
it'd be very difficult to raise or I
think it would be difficult to raise any
child it is I think it doesn't matter if
your child is the most brilliant perfect
whatever it's everything every kid's got
something I'm not worried about that
because like I just feel like you know I
really do feel like I would be a good
mom
I just think I'm worried about the other
things and what it means to be a child
and what it means to be a child in the
world today and like all like we didn't
have the same fears growing up like you
know the school shootings scare me just
say they're doing active Shooters
well the first two which is traumatizing
the first school shooting I experienced
I was in fifth grade and that's when
Columbine happened okay but even then we
weren't doing school shooting drills
because it wasn't like oh this is gonna
happen all the time we just thought
these were like isolated incidents but
like that stuff we you know I still
remember when we did earthquake drills
yeah like those were scary like knowing
like I'm trying to understand deathly
weather you know so
um also the internet that stuff worries
me I don't like that kids are raised on
the internet there's just pictures of
them out there
you know so it's it's a different world
I think you have to have like
I don't know a lot of
just a lot of love and a lot of money
and all a lot of therapy
so I don't know about the money part
yeah I didn't grow up with money I had
there's a different time then I also had
hate but there was love yeah it was a
different time then but honestly like as
a parent the biggest thing you can do is
be there be there and whatever they're
into
the [__] go full force into
supporting you don't have to like it you
have to when I say a lot of money I mean
in a place where you're able to give the
kid that time
you're probably doing well financially
hopefully
right I mean what do you mean like
little league and free no I mean just
like I'm just like I'm just like no no I
mean like I just I mean like you know
having a job but also like it's not not
that you're so overworked that you can't
give the the kid that time here's the
thing if you love anything the way you
love comedy yeah you're gonna find
comedy time for comedy in your day if
you add a child to that mix you will
find time for if you're a good parent
you'll find time for that child and but
you don't you think kids are expensive
they are they're crazy expensive that's
more of like the crazy expensive it's
like kids are it's it's I think yeah
it's not just medical bills and stuff
like no backpacks yeah they grow yeah
they grow I just bought my daughter size
one shoes she's already a one and a half
like two months later I'm like damn we
gotta get new shoes on you know clothes
that's why I say like you have to have
for me it's like you have to have enough
money to make sure that that kid has at
least everything all the other kids have
not know the basic stuff like basically
you know what I mean like I'm not
talking about the fancy stuff just that
they have enough that they're not like
you know I don't want a kid to I don't
want to be able to to not be afford to
give my kid that you know what I mean
like
shoes clothes like at least what
everyone else has at the bare minimum
you know
and like a good life I don't I want to
be able to get I would want to be able
to give a kid at least a good life where
they have all their basic needs met yeah
my daughter listen here's the thing
about most kids it's they have what they
need yeah it's the wants of course you
have to temper but what they really need
that they don't know they need is that
love that validation that attention like
I try to I high five the [__] out of my
camera on stuff like good job good job
good job because like you said you just
need valid I want to be validated I'm
not talking to you like your little kid
like I'll give her real reasons I don't
ever say because I said so or because
I'm the parent I give her legit reasons
I go well this is why and I break it
down halfway through most of that she's
like never mind I'm like oh there's the
real reason you don't want to hear that
I also think like you know there's the
there's the participation trophy parents
too which I don't like either it's like
there's got to be a middle ground where
you know if a kid brings home an A minus
that's still an a you know I mean like
that's still a great job you're still in
the a bracket like don't ask the kid why
they didn't get an A
you know what I mean like it's stuff
like that where it's like the little
things like that kids need you remember
that huh forever did you get bees
oh yeah b c's D's
so you it depends on like math was the
worst but English History all that other
stuff I always tested High pun intended
but
um I I was always testing like I was
smart but it just didn't reflect in
school because of
um my learning you know differences now
what about your sister do you have a
close relationship with your sister
um on and off like we've we've been
close and not close over the years and
um a lot of that has been because I
lived on the opposite side of the
country and you know she went off to be
a lawyer and like her job yeah she's
you're the only one not I know you're
the only non-attorney in the family is
that right mm-hmm
yeah so
um you know she went and followed in the
in the footsteps of my parents your
parents still together wow yeah that's
great
yeah
so um yeah she's and she lives in Vegas
with them all right why did you decide
to go to college in Vermont did you just
want to get way the hell away from
everything
um was it a different start that school
that I went to is called Landmark
College and it's for kids who have
learning differences such as ADHD
um autism
um
uh ADHD add
um executive functioning dyslexia is a
big one so you have to have a learning
difference
um to go there not that autism is a
learning difference but you you most a
lot of the kids could be on the Spectrum
per se because a lot of these run
together
um together you can have multiple
diagnoses so you have to be diagnosed
with a learning difference to go there
it's a two-year School in Vermont and my
parents thought it would be good for me
because it's isolated in a small town
and there's no distractions
um no not really like I I think also I I
didn't have really the grades to go to
us other schools it was kind of one of
my only options and the whole thing is
you go to the school for two years you
get your great you get good grades and
you can go off to other colleges so
after I graduate there I got into
Northeastern and American and I ended up
going to American
in this DC right yeah my cousin went
there for a little bit I went there for
a year
um
what was it like when you first were
able to honestly I don't mean to say it
like this but make your own decisions
about life
like you're out of this college now
where no one had any
um say where you go next like what was
that like for you I mean very foreign
because
after being monitored for 13 months and
literally having to ask permission to
Simply go to the bathroom like
everything you did you had to get
pre-approved
um I was still under that
um
that feeling of like
questioning myself and
again I wasn't being validated for
um anything I just felt very unsure and
a lot of it was
um I'm lucky because
when I got to Vermont I had a boyfriend
there and his mom worked at the college
her name is Kim and she became like a
second mom to me and she's super crunchy
granola like completely opposite of the
people I was in in Utah with and so her
and her husband came became like this
mom and dad that I emotionally never had
like
and they were the ones who made me feel
normal for the first time in my life
that everything I had gone through and
how I was feeling and almost made me be
like we don't even you know that
medication like almost like there's
whatever is going on under that needs to
be addressed but the medication is just
numbing you out you know and like who
you are is okay
lithiums that's some heavy stuff when
did you finally stop taking that uh I
was I was 12 I was only I was only on it
for like a year or so so I was 12 when I
got put on but at that point when I was
in college I was on like still on
tranquilizers still on mood stabilizers
still on all that stuff
Lexapro all that Seroquel everything
Lamictal
um
you know so so basically I for the first
time in my life when I got to college I
was meeting people who validated me and
I started to get good grades because I I
was in a school that taught me how to
learn
because I I just didn't learn the same
way that other like everyone learns
differently in the school system at
least in America as it catered to like
one type of learner
and I knew I would I was told I was
smart my whole life but I didn't never
felt smart because my grades never
reflected that and it wasn't until
college that I actually start to like
see myself as an as somewhat intelligent
good um
all right now after I told you at the
end of this I would ask you advice that
you would give to your 16 year old self
so uh I'm interested to know now because
that's that's right at that pivotal
moment for you what would you say to 16
year old Rachel
strap in
I guess the shit's about to get wild is
it yeah just yeah
um you know
I don't know just uh
yeah
get good
being okay with being yourself I guess
that's great advice yeah
um thank you thank you for doing this I
know that wasn't it I'm proud of you
didn't cry I'm not gonna do it yeah you
did good
um promote everything one more time
please
um Rachel Wolfson on Twitter sorry wrong
at Rachel Wolfson on Instagram at
wolfiecomedia on Twitter and Rachel
wolfsoncomedy.com for my dates and
Wolfie DMS if you guys want to see all
the naughty nasty funny humbling
[Laughter]
I get yeah so that's pretty much it
thank you for having me yeah of course
um as always Ryan sickler on all social
media Ryan sickler.com Tacoma I will see
you this weekend I'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you